Thank you so much David for the introduction and invitation.
I would like to tell you a little bit about the work that we have been doing in our lab.
I'm an engineer by training.
By the way, I'm a chemical engineer who turned bio-engineer.
So, I'm going to tell you about my perspective on
solving an important problem in designing therapeutics.
My lab works in the field of drug delivery,
so that's pretty much what I'm going to talk about today.
But an important aspect of drug delivery is
dealing with the barrier that the body has posed.
So, I'm going to tell you about what those barriers are,
why are they problematic,
and what can we do to overcome them.
But before we start talking about the future of therapeutics,
I think it's worthwhile taking a look at the current landscape.
What are some of the important drugs out there that have changed our lives?
Depending on what your favorite drug is,
you may have a different view on this,
but maybe one way to look at this is,
look at the drugs which had been a huge commercial success.
These five drugs are the most blockbuster drugs to date,
that have been designed by the pharmaceutical and biotech industry.
They cover a number of diseases of some common themes there.
Cardiovascular comes up as a key area,
arthritis, and today they have made
a lot of money to pharmaceutical and biotech companies.
Starting with Lipitor, the most blockbuster drug in history,
has made about $150 billion,
all the way to Plavix to $84 billion.
That is really a great story,
because when I tell people,
my friends and family,
that I'm working in the field of drug delivery,
in their mind these are the example that they see.
They have impacted their lives,
they have improved their lives,
so that's actually the positive side of what we do.
But there is a dark side to what we do.
The dark side being that the cost of developing new drugs is currently very high.
Now these numbers, I have gotten from a reference and
numbers might be different depending on who you talk to.
But roughly, it takes about three billion dollars and 12 years to make a new drug.
When your drug is successful,
like the ones I listed here,
that's wonderful, but these are only few examples.
A lot of drugs don't make that much money.
So when you look at the cost to benefit ratio of the pharmaceutical and biotech industry,
that does actually raise a concern as to how can we
sustain the kind of innovation that we need to move this field forward.
This three billion dollar is a lot of money.
I think it's very interesting to put that in perspective.
So this thing here,
this is Mars Rover Curiosity and it took off from planet Earth.
It's landing on a foreign planet,
moving around, taking pictures,
sending data, and the cost of developing this thing is about $2.5 billion.
So, isn't it interesting that it's cheaper to send
something to a place that most of us have never seen,
only seen in pictures,
and which is still millions of miles away,
but it takes as much money, if not more,
to send something down our throat,
into our body to treat a disease.
Why is that? I guess maybe,
a simple answer is that we understand the laws
of physics much better than we understand the laws of biology,
but nevertheless, to me that's a big problem.
How can we understand body better,
and how can we make sure that we can make
the drugs in a more effective way and cheaper way.
Now, how do we do that?
How can we bring the cost of drug development down?
There are many aspects of that problem.
Again, depending on who you talk to,
you might get a different answer.
But to me, the art and science of developing
a new drug is really fighting this war between safety and efficacy.
What I mean by that is,
when you're doing your experiment in a Petri dish,
on a bunch of cells,
or on a model substrate,
and trying to look for a molecule that can become a drug,
there are many success stories.
Now chemotherapy drugs for an example,
there are many molecules that can kill cancer cells in the test tube,
but when you try to take it to animals and humans,
that's where most things fall because the barrier or the burden of safety is so high,
that we are not able to dose the patients at the dose that we need to,
to make the drug effective.
Whenever there is a tug of war between efficacy and safety,
safety always wins because the first rule of
drug development is that you do not want to do any harm.
So because of that,
many drugs that we hope will reach the patients are not delivered properly,
are not dosed properly,
and the burden basically leads to the fact that many drugs
are essentially sub-optimal in the way they are delivered.
Again, maybe one simplest example is that,
if all you want to do is to kill cancer,
if you can deliver that drug selectively to the tumor side,
many more drugs can be effectively used for that application.
So, why is it that it is so difficult to control where the drug goes into the body?
That entire problem comes from biological barriers.
The body is not designed to distribute the drugs the way we want.
It is designed to control its own metabolism,
and there are very complex set of principles that dictate that.
Most of the time when you deliver drugs,
you are fighting those and not using those.
Let me give you a few examples.
So, body's outermost barrier, skin,
one of the most formidable barrier that the body has built,
because the skins job is to keep things out,
and without that, we wouldn't survive.
If we lose the ability of the skin to form the protection layer against the pathogens,
against water loss, we would dehydrate in a very short period of time.
So, thankfully because of the skin,
we are all alive.
But now imagine trying to deliver drugs across the skin,
the skin does not allow it.
There are very few small molecules which can cross the skin if you put on it.
But try putting a protein or a peptide which
is really where the therapeutic landscape is going to,
less than one percent of
the topically applied drug will enter the skin if you are trying to deliver a protein.
The problem continues if you try to deliver the drug by pill.
Won't it be nice if you can deliver proteins orally?
But when you deliver proteins orally,
less than 0.1 Percent of what you ingest will end up in a blood circulation,
because the GI track is not designed to transport proteins,
it is designed to digest the proteins.
So whatever protein we consume,
it's going to be digested into its building blocks.
Even if some protein escapes from the stomach into the intestine,
the mucus layer on the intestine and the epithelium of the intestine is going to make it
very difficult for this protein to enter from the mouth into bloodstream.
Again, for the most part,
that's good because we don't want the proteins we eat to end up in the blood circulation.
But if you're trying to deliver insulin orally for diabetic patients,
you're not going to be able to do that if you don't design a good system.
If you go inside the body,
the barriers don't go away.
For example, if you're trying to deliver a nanoparticle which can carry you a drug,
imagine injecting that into the blood circulation,
and you want it to go to a specific tissue,
but the liver is going to take the biggest cut because
liver's job is to make sure that no foreign circulating particles exist in the body.
So, most of the nanoparticles eventually end up in the liver and the spleen.
So if you're trying to target something like tumors,
you're going to have very few particles left which can do that effectively.
If you're trying to deliver the drug into the brain,
which is again one of the most formidable barrier that the body has built.
Brain is a highly privileged organ.
It doesn't really want things from the blood to freely enter into the brain.
It has built a very sophisticated barrier which
not only prevent the entry of foreign things into the brain,
but whatever enters the brain is pumped back into the blood.
So, very advanced barrier built between the brain and the blood,
which makes it very difficult to deliver drugs into
the brain for the treatment of neurological disorders.
So when you look at these numbers,
one percent delivery efficiencies,
they really bother me as an engineer.
When you look at other parts of engineering where people have developed new technologies,
like transportation for example.
If I were to tell you that you can take a taxi,
but only one percent of the time you will reach your destination,
we would never take that taxi.
If you think about airplanes,
that level of efficiency is not acceptable,
but somehow in the field of drug development,
this low efficiency which had become a building block,
instead of trying to overcome it,
we try to work around it.
That ultimately leads to high costs and long-term development times.
So our goal in the lab has been to understand,
how can we overcome these barriers,
develop mathematical models to predict them,
and develop new tools and technologies to overcome these barriers so
that we can deliver the drugs through the route that we want,
to the location we want.
With those sort of technologies,
I think the cost and time of drug development can come significantly down.
Another key challenge that we are going to face in the field of drug delivery,
is that the therapeutic landscape is changing dramatically as we speak.
So if you look at how drugs have evolved over a period of time,
if you go back in history,
most drugs were small molecules.
They were extracts from plants' natural molecules.
I wouldn't say it was easy to deliver them,
but easier than the drug that we're facing today.
The biggest challenge there,
was how to solubilize those molecules, molecules like Paclitaxel.
So a lot of effort earlier was focused on figuring out solubilization.
Then came small peptides and proteins like insulin,
almost a 100 years ago,
that increased the challenge of delivery.
Then came antibodies, which are not only much larger
in size compared to typical proteins like insulin,
but they are also required in large doses.
So that adds another layer of complexity.
Then came nucleic acid,
where you not only had to deliver them into the body,
but you basically had to deliver them across
the cell membrane and sometimes into the nucleus.
So that adds another layer of complexity.
More recently, cells have really come to the table as therapeutic agents.
These are living entities.
When you deliver them into the body they can do their own things.
So as you go from small molecule to cell,
your requirements change dramatically.
So our delivery technologies had to really take that into
account and be as sophisticated as the drug itself.
Because that landscape is changing constantly,
it's needing constant innovation in terms of technologies,
and that I think is a key challenge for people who are working in this field.
So let me give you a couple of examples as to what kind of
drug delivery technologies we are working on and where they are in terms of delivery.
One of the key areas in the lab has been trying to
figure out how can we deliver proteins and peptides across the skin,
so things like insulin,
can we develop a patch or a transdermal patch for insulin?
There are some patches out there like nicotine, testosterone, estrogen.
You can buy a patch for those but they're all small molecules.
If you try to deliver something large,
it's not going to cross the skin.
Why is that? Because the skin is a fantastic barrier.
What you see here is a cross-section of skin.
If you look at the top-most layer of the skin,
this layer here, this is the main reason why your skin is a good barrier.
That's the part that flakes off.
It's only 15 microns in thickness, so extremely thin,
but it's a fantastic barrier to transport up molecules into it.
Once the drug crosses this top-most 15 micron,
it can easily go through the rest of the skin and get absorbed into
blood circulation where the blood capillaries are located right in this region.
If you look at the structure of that top-most layer,
it's literally like a wall where the bricks
are made up of dead cells which are filled with proteins.
In this case, it's mostly keratin,
and the space in between those bricks is filled with lipids.
These are not ordinary lipids that you find in cell membranes.
These are the lipids which have very long chain.
What that means is that they exist in
a very solid gel-like phase and that makes them very difficult to cross.
Even one lipid bi-layer of this kind is enough to stop the entry of the drug.
In the case of skin,
the drug has to cross about 50 to 100 of those before getting into blood circulation.
So that's the level of challenge we are dealing with for transdermal delivery.
So we had been figuring out how to overcome this.
The first tool that we developed makes use of ultrasound.
So this is the device that actually came out of the research.
It's a device about this big.
This particular piece sits on our desk and there's a handpiece.
You put that handpiece on the skin wherever you want to make the skin permeable.
When you turn the device on,
it sends sound waves at high frequency, the ultrasound waves.
In about half a minute,
you make the skin permeable,
about this much spot on the skin is made permeable and that spot
remains permeable for about 18 to 24 hours.
During that time, you can put the patch that drug diffuses
across that open spot and enter the blood circulation.
The way it works is that ultrasound causes cavitation,
it forms pockets of gas.
So this gas bubbles form on the surface of the skin and they expand.
At one point, they collapse.
That collapse is very sudden,
it sends a shockwave and that shockwave can make the skin permeable.
So this device was approved by the FDA for delivering local anesthesia.
It has been used to deliver a number of other molecules.
It's been tested in clinical studies to deliver vaccines.
Many other studies have been done with
additional molecules which are difficult to deliver.
About a couple of years ago,
this device was used in another clinical study.
In this case, it was a different challenge but also dealing with the barrier.
So here, we were trying to use ultrasound for the treatment of acne.
The idea was the following,
that when somebody has acne,
the sebaceous glands, the sweat glands are overactive.
They are producing a lot of sebum and that blocks
the channel and that leads to
the formation or the growth of bacteria and eventually, inflammation.
So we wanted to send these nanoparticles into the deep glands.
These are core-shell nanoparticle.
They have a silica core.
Surrounding the core is a shell of gold.
When you hit them with laser,
the gold shell absorb the laser and becomes extremely hot.
The temperature of that nanoparticle can become hot enough to
basically locally charge the tissue but it's extremely local.
So even a few microns away from that nanoparticle,
you don't feel any heat.
So it's a very local,
very focused way of inducing heat or imparting heat to the tissue.
The only challenge is that how can you get
those nanoparticles into the gland where it needs to work,
and that's where ultrasound came to the rescue.
We put nanoparticles on the skin,
applied ultrasound, and particles were delivered deep into the gland,
and then we have done with laser and you can essentially
kill the local sweat gland and that has beneficial effects.
So this was tested in a number of
human volunteers and was published a couple of years ago,
led to very interesting benefits in terms of the appearance and the progression of acne.
But we were also interested in developing simpler to use formulations.
By formulations, I mean a gel or an ointment that you can put easily on
the skin that has its own benefits in terms of reaching to a large skin area,
in terms of simplicity,
in terms of cost of development.
We're wondering, what would be a good foundation to develop a technology like that.
We started thinking about ionic liquids in that context.
So ionic liquids are basically liquid salts just like sodium chloride,
except that in the case of sodium chloride,
you have a sodium and a chloride ion, they're very small.
So they form a solid.
If you take a large cation and large anion, they form a liquid.
We did a lot of studies to understand how do
the properties of ions relate to their outcome.
Out of that study came
one particular ionic liquid which is a combination of geranic acid and choline.
We like these two molecules for a number of reasons.
So geranic acid is a natural molecule.
It's present in oranges and lemongrass.
It's currently used as a food flavorant.
It has a very citrusy kind of aroma to it.
So it's used as a food enhancer or an aroma enhancer.
Choline is present in a number of natural ingredients, predominantly eggs.
But more importantly, it's taken as a dietary supplement by large number of individuals.
So we said that's interesting.
If you take these two molecules with a history of use in humans,
and by combining them,
if you get a new ionic liquid that can do something very interesting,
that would be a fantastic opportunity.
We did that and out of that came the ionic liquid that we call CAGE.
It's an acronym for choline and geranic acid.
It looks like this.
CAGE is a viscous liquid,
almost like a honey consistency liquid in that bottle there.
The liquid only has two molecules,
choline and geranic acid.
But the way they come together,
they form this very interesting liquid which can solubilize drugs,
which can enhance the transport of drugs into the skin.
One molecule that we are very interested in delivering is insulin,
as I mentioned early on.
So we said, let's see if we can deliver insulin with CAGE.
So we took CAGE,
we added insulin to it.
In the beginning, we did a simple transport experiment.
We took pig skin and put insulin on the surface of the skin.
Here is the control experiment where we put insulin,
insulin hardly anything goes through,
that's to be expected because insulin has essentially no skin permeability.
But when we deliver insulin from CAGE,
we see deep penetration into the skin.
Here up to about almost a millimeter into the skin,
we see insulin entering in significant quantities which is very difficult to do.
So that was very exciting.
Is it really biologically active?
So we did an experiment in a rat model where we put insulin in cage on the rat,
and that data is shown here.
So if you look at the red graph,
that's the glucose level of the rat where we have put insulin in cage on the surface,
and you see a steady decrease in the glucose concentration,
and the glucose concentration remains low for a long period of time.
So you can get that sustained delivery of insulin across the skin into blood circulation.
In contrast, if you just use a salient solution,
you hardly see any penetration.
The blue line here is positive controls.
So if you inject it, that obviously works,
you do see a drop in glucose level,
but just a quick drop and a quick recovery.
So there is a certain change in the glucose level.
In contrast, if you put a patch on the skin,
you can potentially get sustained release over a long period of time.
So that's where a transdermal patch can make a significant impact.
Not only it can deliver the drug into the body,
but it can change the rate at which it goes into the body.
It can also provide a new feature in terms of therapeutic benefits.
Oral delivery as you know has been a holy grail so to speak where question is,
can you deliver proteins and peptides using a simple pill?
Pill has its own appeal in the sense that we're all used
to taking pills, vitamin, headache medicines.
So if we can deliver many molecules that way,
the thought is that would be certainly welcomed from the patient.
So here, I'm showing you some data of where we made a pill that contains same cage,
ionic liquid and in which we are suspending
insulin and we're delivering that to rat in this case.
If you look at the graph on the right-hand side just for the moment,
what it basically shows you is that compared to
a quick drop that you see in the case of injection,
you can get a sustained drop in glucose levels when you deliver this orderly.
So it was very interesting because there are
very few technologies that I'm aware of where
the same kind of technology platform works
against multiple platforms and multiple barriers.
In the previous slide, I showed you that it enhances transport across the skin.
Here, it's enhancing transport across the GI tract.
So it has some very interesting features that we are currently exploring.
In the context of order delivery,
cage does a few things.
It's a good enzyme inhibitor.
So it inhibits the enzymes in the stomach.
It's a good view catalytic agents.
So when the drug reaches the mucus layer,
it can clean it out and enhance transport across the mucus layer
and it also is able to open the tight junctions in the epithelium,
so can enhance the permutation.
So it can address all key barriers that are faced in terms of protein delivery.
When you go inside the body,
your barrier certainly don't go away.
As I mentioned, they exist in different form.
So that's also something we are quite eager to explore.
The thought here is that,
you would take a drug,
encapsulate that in a nanoparticle,
it could be a polymeric nanoparticle, could be a hydrogel,
could be a liposome, and you want
that nanoparticle to go to a certain tissue in the body.
Now obviously, that doesn't happen as effectively because nanoparticles get cleared.
While we are looking at it,
a question we started asking is,
why is it that there is such a huge contrast between how the body deals
with foreign entities like nanoparticles compared to its own cells?
If you think about circulating cells,
each one of them has a feature that we wish
and hope that our synthetic nanoparticles can accomplish.
For example, if you want your nanoparticle,
if you want your drug to stay in circulation for a long period of time,
look at the red blood cells.
Each red blood cell stays in circulation for
about four months and after its time is up, it gets cleared.
But, there is no therapeutic.
There is no small molecule,
there is no large molecule,
no nanoparticle which can come close to staying in circulation for four months.
If you want your material,
your therapeutic to bind selectively to blood vessel or somewhere in the body,
look at what platelets do.
So platelets are inactive in their native state,
but whenever there is damage to the blood vessel,
they get activated, they bind selectively and amplify
the signal to really induce the formation of the clot.
So that self-amplifying highly targeted mechanism of binding
is inherent to the platelets in a way that
is very challenging for a nanoparticle to mimic.
If you want your particles,
you are therapeutic to go deep into the tissue,
look at what macrophages do.
Now, macrophages stay in the circulation for a long time.
Their job is to do immune surveillance.
But, whenever they sense something wrong in the tissue,
they escape the blood vessel and go deep into
the tissue in a way that nanoparticles cannot.
If you think about how drugs and nanoparticles navigate themselves in the tissues,
they do so by diffusion,
and diffusion is extremely slow.
So it takes a long time for them to go deep into the tissue.
So many people who are developing therapies for cancer,
they have realized that the drugs can access the surface of the tumor,
but not deep inside because of the poor diffusion into the tissue.
But, macrophages had no such problem.
They can go straight deep into the tumor.
So the question we have been asking is,
what can we learn from these natural examples and how can we adopt some of
those principles into designing
synthetic carriers which can deliver drugs in a better way.
If you look at the contrast between
natural cells like red blood cells and synthetic materials,
what are the differences between
these two systems which can drive such different response?
If we get better at synthesizing newer materials,
and if you understand the biological systems in a better way,
can we mend the two and begin to coexist in this intermediate range where we can
use biomimetic strategies to overcome some of the key hurdles in drug delivery.
Now, when you look at these two systems and you say what is different,
and you say, "Well, a lots of things are different.
Their surface is different,
their competition is different."
But as an engineer, I really got intrigued by the differences in the physical properties.
Their shapes are different,
their flexibility is different.
So question we've been asking is,
these physical parameters, do they really make
a difference in terms of their behavior in the body?
So the first step was to make synthetic particles that can span different shapes,
which is very difficult to do because if you're making a material or making
a particle or sphere is energetically most favorable shapes.
So going away from that always poses a challenge.
So one of my talented graduate students,
Julie Champion, who was a faculty member at Georgia Tech,
she figured out a way to make particles of different shapes starting
from disk to rods to UFO-shaped particles,
if somebody wants them.
Then she started asking,
does it really make a difference?
One of the first experiments she did,
was she fed them to the macrophages.
Long story short, it turned out that,
it made a huge difference.
Whether or not particles went inside the cells in a way that depends on the shape.
So if you have a macrophage and if you have
a rod-like particle that approaches the cell with the pointy end,
it got internalized very quickly.
But, if the same particle come from the side,
it was not able to get internalized.
So from the cell's point of view,
shape made a huge difference in terms of the outcome of this interaction.
That led us to all kinds of interesting questions as to how
to other aspects of particle interaction are impacted by the shape.
We found out that if you take an antigen lack of vaccine and put that on the particle,
the way the immune cell pursues that vaccine is very
different depending on whether you have a sphere or a rod-like particle.
That may have some origins as to how pathogens are processed by the immune system,
where pathogens that come in very unique shapes could have
some potential advantage in terms of their inherent immunogenicity.
The way the body generates an allergic response to nanoparticles also depends on shape.
So those of you who are active in the field of nanomedicine may be aware of this that,
allergic reaction to nanoparticles is a huge concern for some of the nanoparticles.
A couple of years ago, we showed that simply taking
a sphere and turning that into a rod-like particle,
you can essentially mitigate most of the allergic response in the animal model.
Same thing happens with respect to particles softness.
So here, we made particles of the same material,
but we changed their softness.
We made a soft version of it,
which is almost like a gel cell membrane like elasticity,
and we made a hard virgin,
and when we inject these two particles in the blood,
we found out that the softer particles circulate for a much longer time.
They escape the clearance by the immune system much more significantly,
and that basically gave us an idea as to how important these elastic properties are,
which in hindsight makes sense because
most materials or most entities in the body are soft.
Made from either proteins, or lipids,
and compared to that,
most synthetic materials are very hard.
So inherently, they stand out as foreign entities.
So softness is a key parameter in our mind.
So, when you combine these two parameters,
the shape and the elasticity that is inherent to biological systems,
we started wondering if we put them together can we make some interesting materials?
So, our first attempt at that was to make synthetic red blood cells,
and by that I mean particles that physically look like red blood cells.
So, the picture on the left those are our particles sRBC.
So, this synthetic red blood cells made from proteins and polyelectrolytes,
and on the left-hand side,
you see natural mouse red blood cells.
So, if you compare the morphology of these two,
you can begin to imagine the structural similarity that we're quite excited about.
Just like natural red blood cell,
these soft particles can squeeze themselves through small capillaries,
they can carry oxygen if you load hemoglobin into them.
So, you can begin to build for
a complex architectures and functionalities into these particles.
Going one step beyond,
we wondered whether we can mimic platelets to make synthetic platelets.
That is an important medical problem because there is currently
no synthetic material that you can inject
in the blood as a replacement for natural platelets.
So, If somebody's bleeding profusely,
there is no treatment other than natural platelet that you can use.
But the problem with Max-Cut platelets that you cannot store them,
so that's always a challenge.
So, we made these particles.
These are completely synthetic particles we made using albumin.
They have a similar size and shape like natural platelets,
and we put targeting ligands on them to make
them bind to the blood vessel minute is damaged,
and we did a simple test to see if the stop bleeding.
So, compared to a salient control,
the synthetic platelets were able to reduce
the breeding type dramatically and currently we are building on
to that to see if we can move them to the next stage of development.
While we are trying to mimic the principles of natural cells,
we realize we're not quite there yet,
so it's more of a lifelong query than a quick fix.
We wondered while we are working on it,
can we somehow make use of
the circulatory cells to bring on some of these functionalities into synthetic particles.
So, for example, if we cannot design
a nanoparticle that can stay in circulation for a long time,
can we just make them hitch a ride on red blood cell?
So, we designed nanoparticles which are attached themselves to red blood cells.
So, you can see a red blood cell with number of particles attached to it.
The underlying question was actually quite fascinating.
Now, imagine that complex of red blood cell and nanoparticles arriving in the liver,
and the macrophage is looking at it and it sees a foreign signal coming from
the particle and self signal coming from the red blood cell who's going to win,
and what tips that balance?
So, it lead us to very interesting set of questions
which I'll be happy to discuss with you at a later time.
But the first key question we wanted to ask is,
does it stains circulation?
So, compared to free particles,
which get cleared from the blood before we know it,
this is an experiment in a rat.
So, these free particles most of them got clear even before we could measure.
If you simply put d one red blood cell,
this time circulation for a much longer.
If you put polyethylene glycol on the surface of this exposed particle,
you can keep them in circulation for even longer,
you can keep them in the circulation for days,
so that really opens up new functionalities from these particles.
So, what happens to them eventually?
The particles do come off over a period of time.
What happens is that when these complexes of
red blood cells and nanoparticles go to small capillaries,
the red blood cell gets stretched and its particle
gets attached to the endothelium the surface of the blood vessel.
So, it's a great way of transferring a particle
from the red blood cell to the surface of the blood vessel.
Red blood cell itself is basically let go,
it continues to circulate.
So, if you look at the circulation of red blood cell itself,
it is not impacted.
Turns out that the strategy has been used by pathogens.
So what you see here is an electron micrograph of hemoparty nella,
it's a bacterium that's found in cattle,
and it has found a way to attach itself to red blood cell,
and by doing so it can avoid clearance from the circulation.
So, some really smart pathogens have figured it out way before we did.
This strategy works for a variety of particles.
So, here we have used hydrogen nanoparticles,
liposomes, polymer particles, protein particles,
they all work about the same principle because it's
a very physically driven mechanism not chemistry specific.
These particles tend to go to the lungs.
They do so because lung has largest number of capillaries per unit mass.
So, when these complexes go to the lung capillaries,
the particles are dislodged from the red blood cell by the endothelium.
So, it's a great way of targeting nanoparticles with the lungs.
If you don't want lungs,
if you want them to go somewhere else,
you can do that as well.
So, here we get this red blood cell nanoparticle complexes in the artery,
and then they go to the brain.
So, here we are getting about 10 percent of the injected dose to go into the brain.
The significance of that is that number is among
the highest fraction of nanoparticle
delivered to the brain compared to what people have seen.
Even the best performing antibody that people are discovering for
the purpose of entering the brain is not able to come even close.
So, we are very excited about the potential of targeting
nanoparticles to different organs and based on this principle.
Once you like hitting right,
why stop at red blood cells start hitching ride on all kinds of cells,
and we like to ride on macrophages and monocytes.
We like them because they know how to get deep into the tissues.
So, here we figured out a way to attach a particle to macrophage.
The difficult thing about macrophages that unlike
red blood cells which are happy to take your particle,
macrophages want to eat it too because that's their job.
So, we figured out that if you make a disc shaped particle and that is flexible,
it can attach to the macrophage,
but not get internalize.
If you give them spheres, they will just gobble it up.
This little particle can go for a ride wherever the macrophage goes.
The macrophage really holds onto it.
So, it doesn't go anywhere,
and it's thin enough so that it doesn't hinder the macrophage,
so it's a great way to get into different tissues in the body.
So, what we're doing with it right now,
our main target is to use this for the treatment of cancers,
with the idea that if you take a large tumor,
any typical large tumor,
it has macrophages in massive quantities.
That happens because macrophages is a key part of body's innate immune system,
so when tumor develops,
these macrophages go in there and monocytes as well.
The initial approach is to attack the tumor,
but the tumor override that signal and they become
essentially part of the tumor because they're very plastic in nature.
So, we are delivering cytokines from these backpacks,
so that we constantly reminding the macrophage to take on
an anti-tumor phenotype so as to launch an anti-tumor response.
So, currently we're in the middle of the studies,
and I hope to have more to tell about that in the coming months to a year.
Where we see this field overall going is that,
we as materials scientists had met a lot of
progress in making different kinds of materials, liposomes,
nanoparticles, and the interface between
the material world and
the cellular world coming from red blood cells macrophages and T-cells,
they existed in two different parts of the world.
But as we get better and better in terms of designing complex nanoparticles and either
using them as an inspiration to make
this particles or simply feature ride on them for the time being,
we can begin to blend a gap between these two and that I
think really opens up new opportunities
especially as the world-up therapeutics is
beginning to think of cells as a key part in the drug landscape.
So, let me end my talk here,
and maybe save some time for questions.
This is the slide I showed you early on in terms
of the biological barrier that we're facing.
With the technology that we had developed in the lab,
we are making significant progress in terms of overcoming these barriers.
So, for a skin,
we had gone from one percent,
to about 20 percent in terms of delivery of insulin and nucleic acids.
Foreign testing, we had gone from very low number for
oral uptake to high double-digit transport of proteins.
In terms of delivering particles within the body,
less than one percent going to the tumor and other target tissues,
we can go up to a high number in terms of targeting or something about the brain.
So, that's a significant improvement in the delivery efficiency across the barriers.
But the bigger impact,
I think of these numbers,
is that the current therapeutic world is very
focused in terms of how certain molecules can be delivered.
For example, when somebody is developing a protein drug,
you immediately think about only injections,
automatically discounting the possibility to use transformer
or oral because of this high barriers.
Once you start crossing these barriers,
that really open some an impacting way.
Once you take away that stereotype,
in terms of which route can be used for which molecule that really enables
not only delivery of these molecules but also impact discovery of new drugs.
That's where I see the future and
huge impact of delivery technologies on the therapeutic landscape.
So let me end here.
I want to end my talk by thanking you for all coming here on a Wednesday evening.
I want to thank all the students who had done this wonderful work that I presented.
The top picture here is a drawing by one of my students.
So, one fine day I go to the lab and I see this drawing on the fume hood,
and it shows how our lab works.
So, everybody in the lab has a job.
So, somebody's responsible for purchasing supplies,
one person is responsible for injecting animals,
and this is me.
My job is to stay in my office and say.
"Sounds great", which is exactly what I do.
So, I'm deeply thankful to all their hard work and thank you again.
Thank you for the invitation,
and if there's time I'll be happy to answer questions.